anxiety and you know my anxiety
eventually led to a lot of avoided
Behavior
so when I was a kid my dad used to get
really upset with me because
um of my shyness like I couldn't talk to
people it was damn near impossible and
you know my dad would get so upset at me
about the stuff he would like in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast if you are just checking
in on this video you must be in for a
[__] surprise because I'm just going
to be honest there is no guest today and
this is going to be a relatively short
podcast but I know people be listening
to this podcast either when they're at
work or they're just you know they just
want a little giggle and they want their
[__] to feel nice so look David So
delivers okay uh yeah I'm talking to
myself and we're talking to you right
now we're gonna go through a couple of
things
um
specifically there's you know I had like
this genius brain email that I don't
really check anymore but I used to have
it out there as a link for you guys to
be able to ask for questions and advice
and sometimes they be really good
questions a lot of the times it was the
same questions over and over and over
again and I'm just gonna address a
couple of them real quick
um
a question that I get asked a lot number
one and for some [__] reason I don't
understand why guys are obsessed with
this it's like penis size [__] listen
here you weird [__]
stop asking about penis size stop asking
about peanut if this if you're an adult
right if you are somebody who has lived
past the age I don't know let's say 25
and you're still going online asking
other people about how big your dick
should be it doesn't matter you're never
going to use it anyways nobody likes you
let's start with that okay look
I could go in and have a conversation
and talk about okay I know x amount of
studies I saw this video that video
about this this and that at the end of
the [__] day if you're worried about
how big your dick is most likely you're
not even talking to women in the first
place so it doesn't really matter ain't
nobody gonna touch it nobody even sees
it you barely look at it because you're
scared all right relax it's okay move
the [__] on man you know
it's weird when I was younger right
I specifically remember this [__] you
guys remember the first time you ever
watched porn
I remember when I was a kid and you know
obviously for you guys who are who are
younger than me I'm 35 now uh you may
not remember the first time that you had
access to like high-speed internet well
I do and the first thing that I did when
I got high-speed internet I didn't
research anything I didn't use it for
the knowledge that was out there I
looked for material to whack my [__] off
to another universe and I watch porn and
I remember when I was younger and I saw
porn I was surprised at how big the
dicks were
I'm not gonna lie I remember looking at
the dicks and I said one day when I grow
up my dick is going to be that big and
guess what
never happened it never [__] happened
had no idea why I was figuring out okay
is my [__] defective don't know what's
[__] going on here's what I found out
nobody [__] cares okay there are
people who care right obviously there's
[__] size queens
and stuff like that but
at the end of the day if you're asking
strangers and remember though we've
known each other for quite a while on
this Internet space technically we are
strangers and if you're wondering about
dick size so much enough to ask me as if
I'm packing heat
I'm not
I don't know what a good size is I don't
know and a lot of the times too
especially with guys right when it comes
to advice like this you shouldn't be
asking a guy you should probably ask
women
especially when it comes to dating
advice like when you ask a guy like Hey
how do women want to be spoken to maybe
you should talk to a [__] girl you
don't have any homegirls maybe talk to a
cousin maybe your aunt maybe your mom
women will probably give you better
advice about how they want to be treated
like or how they would like to be spoken
to
and when you ask somebody like me I can
only give you like perspective from
like my mistakes right so okay let's go
into this topic
because either way the the the question
another reoccurring question is like is
always dating questions and like how to
talk to girls I was never very good at
talking to women surprise no nobody's
[__] surprised
uh it wasn't like that when I was
younger I was very awkward and I had
trouble with eye contact right and even
till this day I don't like making eye
contact a lot not because well now the
reasons are a little bit different okay
that's enough okay I'm letting my ADHD
take on but uh
like
talking to people was very difficult for
me when I was younger
um and I've talked about this a lot
where I've had where I dealt with a
ridiculous amount of anxiety and you
know my anxiety eventually led to a lot
of avoided Behavior
so uh when I was a kid my dad used to
get really upset with me because
um of my shyness like I couldn't talk to
people it was damn near impossible and
you know my dad would get so upset at me
about the stuff he would like whoop my
ass he would you know obviously he would
try to encourage me in the most part of
positive ways too but it wasn't working
so he would get frustrated he'd whoop my
ass because I just couldn't do anything
I couldn't order food I couldn't talk to
people I couldn't look at people in the
eyes it was so [__] difficult
um
and it was something that I really hated
about myself right because I was always
a goofy kid I was really funny in the
house but the moment I stepped
outdoors and I went into the real world
it was very very [__] hard for me to
just even communicate with people
in in like the most simple ways possible
right and that led that led to me being
really socially awkward as a younger kid
and look
and you know I and I wondered too later
on like where I got this from and now
that I look at my dad now that I'm an
adult and then I see my father as an
adult as well my dad's actually very
socially awkward so I kind of understood
why he hated the fact that I couldn't
talk to people why I was so shy is
because I feel that I've never spoken to
him about this but if I think about it
you know
the saying goes that we hate the
qualities
and others that we see in ourselves
right and I think my dad hated the fact
that I kind of took on this this
you know not so good trait in his eyes
um that I took it on is you know it
probably came from him and it probably
messed with him a little bit and it
frustrated uh him that you know
that I had a call that he hated about
himself and his son had it so I think
that's why he got mad that's why he
probably yelled at me he whooped my ass
and stuff like that because he was
trying to make sure that he that I
didn't have this bad quality that he you
know inherently had
I'm being repetitive here but
um
so how that kind of leads into me you
know talking to women and dating and
stuff like that which something I
couldn't do before when I was younger
um I learned to recognize this problem
that I had and a lot of the times when
it comes to being a social person for
people who aren't social right because
I've spoken about this before where I'm
very introverted
it's it's this conversation that I have
within my head of
this temporary discomfort is going to
lead to something better
right everything that I have now in life
and a lot of the stuff that I I really
enjoy or have enjoyed doing happened
because I convinced myself that I was
something that I'm not I'm not an
extroverted person so I had to convince
myself that I was
um
I'm not very good at talking to people
so I had to learn on how to speak to
people
these were things that I wanted to
change about myself and I did actionable
items to make sure that it happened
there are things like for you know just
to go back to the part where you know
how do you talk to women like how do you
think you're going to talk to women
by what
talking to women
and when I say this too
it's going to take a little bit of you
kind of falling face first
and messing up
uh you have no idea how many times I've
been rejected so many [__] times in
fact I have a I should give me a gold
medal baby I'd be getting rejected all I
got rejected so [__] much I just kind
of scabbed over it didn't matter anymore
but every time I did I learned a little
bit about myself oh David you kind of
talk too much here oh David you made too
many jokes here oh why don't you let
them speak you should ask them questions
about themselves instead of you always
talking about yourself okay maybe this
girl doesn't like too many jokes right
and I know it sounds really exhausting
because the typical advice that I used
to give and a lot of other people give
is you know just be yourself true to a
certain extent be yourself to a certain
extent right because you don't you don't
want to hide yourself and you know
um eventually start dating somebody or
be with them giving them an expectation
of who you are when you're really not
that person okay whatever that's fine
but we have to take advice with a great
assault when I say be yourself I mean be
yourself but you still have to learn how
to date right you still have to learn
social cues like in Korean we call it
dunchie like nunchi is like you know
understanding the vibe and if you don't
really get that then dating is going to
be really hard for you and the only way
for you to understand it is for you to
go out there date and get rejected and
kind of [__] up I think in you know when
you're younger you're so scared of
[__] up and making mistakes because
you expect yourself to be perfect
because you look at examples of other
people doing things really well and you
think that they got to that point
without having to fail
see at one point in time they were
probably like you
they were scared they were nervous they
didn't know how to approach people right
and we're also talking about this
outside of just dating and talking to
women
they were once you too see but you're
only looking at the end result and you
don't get to see all the times they they
[__] up and they they I don't know
they embarrassed themselves within a
conversation
and so you kind of expect a lot out of
yourself every time somebody says like
oh what if I [__] up and fail I kind of
look at it as like dude what are you who
the [__] are you like who the [__] do
you think you are you're supposed to
fail a little bit
you're supposed to get you know scabbed
up scratched up whatever the [__] that
you want to call it it's supposed to
happen that way
sometimes
like
I I feel sad and I feel kind of like you
know
I just feel really bad for people who
just are so scared to mess up like there
are so many things in life that you are
kind of foregoing because you're you're
letting fear take over your life and
that's why for me to wrap it back around
like how I kind of got rid of my social
anxiety and that uh and a way for me to
talk to people I just didn't want this
one thing about me to hold me back and
it's something that happened to my
father and you try to change it out of
me so like when I have a kid I want to
be able to teach them how to break out
of their insecurities and their shyness
and a lot of times when we are shy and
we are introverted which I am
uh I enjoy being by myself I enjoy doing
things um alone uh sometimes too many
people around me
um it sucks the energy out of me so when
I get home and I'm by myself I feel more
energized so I know that I'm a lot more
introverted why do you think I love
doing tomatoes in the [__] morning
bro I'm [__] 35 years old I'm out
here in a sun hat farmer's tan [__]
snipping to me I look like a [__] 45
year old ajima I get it
I get it it's because I'm introverted I
like it I like being alone with my
tomatoes I like talking to the sun Golds
the brandy wines the beef steak tomatoes
the Brad's Atomic grapes the Snow Whites
huh the Michael Poland yeah the yellow
pears I could keep on going that's I'm a
little insane right but those moments of
solitude when I'm by myself helps me to
kind of go ahead and start my day right
um which is another great topic by the
way um that was something else that
people wanted to bring up uh uh
paraphrasing it okay
how did I learn like how do I speak so
well
um in group settings when I'm an
introverted person
um this person was asking me like they
they want to learn how to talk to people
and be extroverted and this is the weird
part right like
um
just because I'm inclined to be
introverted like any like introversion
is my thing I mean
um it doesn't necessarily mean that
that's how I want to be at all times I
parcel that [__] out right a majority of
the time I like alone time with this and
by the way it you know I do like hanging
out with people but it's a select amount
of people and it's usually in a small
group
if I have to go out in a setting with a
bunch of people
I'm talking about a bunch of people that
I [__] hate dislike I don't [__]
know and by the way it doesn't
necessarily mean that I hate them it's
just more like I don't want to talk
these people so they're already the
category of I hate your [__] guts
don't talk to me I have to mentally
prepare myself so if you're an
introverted person but you would like to
learn how to be around a groups of
people if you are introverted it's going
to be exhausting but I say before you go
out plan your days Day Out
right if you know you're going to be in
a in a scenario with a lot of people be
prepared for it even if it makes you
uncomfortable and this is where you get
to really grow as a human being as well
because we kind of don't really grow
when we're always comfortable
you grow in like
um in your discomfort right you find the
things that kind of chip away at you
when you kind of fill in these gaps and
these holes and you become a better
person like it's it's weird being an
introvert like an introverted human
being with like high anxiety how I
learned how to do stand-up and you know
I started doing stand-up because
obviously it made people laugh and
buying turn by making people laugh it
made me feel good but it was also a way
for me to kind of face like these weird
um
irrational Fears Head On and just
telling myself I won't die like I told
you about that story a [__] stupid
ass Jason Cheney where he uh where he
ambushed me with that stand-up comedy
said that I didn't know what I was doing
and the only reason why I went up there
was because I had to keep telling myself
like what are you a [__] like you ain't
gonna [__] die go up there and do
something about it
and it was exhausting but after I got
off stage I was really happy with myself
that I actually did it right because I
don't think I would have been able to
sleep at night and it would have kind of
ate me up knowing that I let this
irrational fear
um take over me and take away from this
experience that I could have had with my
friends
that's that's the thing too like as you
guys get older man
that's generally where your thoughts go
because you start to really realize how
finite life is how short life is
you don't get it when you're younger
right because and you shouldn't you
shouldn't be thinking about how short
life is when you're at that age to be
honest with you like in your 20s and
your teens or whatever don't think about
how short life is life seems like it's
an eternity and that's a really great
feeling to have but when you get to that
point where you start to realize that
there's a finite time that you're going
to be alive and by the way you don't
know that number
you don't know when your time is up you
don't know what that guaranteed time is
because in your mind you're thinking
humans life expectancy is what on
average what 80 to 90 years if on on a
good on a good day 80 to 90 years but
you don't know car accident
disease
cancer something else might take you out
you have absolutely no idea
that concept of time as you get older
helps rearrange what's important to you
for me as I got older I realized that I
didn't want
anybody or anything to take away from
the things that I want to experience in
life
especially if it's something that
I can fix personally
right like my anxiety where does my
anxiety come from sitting down and
thinking about it and trying to fix it
and going to therapy helped me out a lot
but if I didn't do these once again like
these you know
put set forth like these actionable
items it would have never corrected
itself well I I would have never been
able to fix it or work towards fixing it
I never want to be on my deathbed one
day and look back and say hey David you
could have done more yeah there's a lot
of things I could do more in right but
I'm talking about do more than things
that I want
right
which is why you don't see me pursuing
certain things that a lot of people feel
like I would be really great at because
those are the things that I don't really
care about if I care about something
enough where I think about it all the
time and I say do what if I could have
done that I'm just going to do it I'm
just going to do it that's why I I did
the film [__] that's why I did hosting
on that that's why I did all these
things was because I wanted to try it
doesn't mean I was going to do it
forever right which a lot of people
think that when you do something you
have to stay committed to it for the
rest of your life no you don't
you absolutely do not life is short once
again and if you want to experience
these things go out and [__]
experience it enjoy [__] life I'm not
committed to [__]
I'm not even committed to my wife I'm
kidding that's a [__] joke I'm
kidding I am committed to my wife I'm
not committed to like these
it's like this
I have met so many people
who have asked me how did you figure it
out and my response is always the same
figure what out what the [__] are you
talking about what the [__] have I
figured out I haven't figured out [__]
my life is a disaster and I enjoy it
life is chaos you don't know what's
going to happen there's nothing that's
guaranteed in life except death
life is chaos and I accept the chaos
even in your careers right you people
ask oh how did you know this is what you
wanted to do I still don't [__] know
I'm not questioning it I'm just working
hard at what I enjoy now
as long as my bases are covered I just
keep doing that
every day
that's what I do
I make sure that I find something that I
can work towards
as long as my bases are covered I don't
have everything figured out stop looking
at individuals and what like how do they
figure some people are very singular
like they can do one thing for the rest
of their life right and then their
careers become their whole life for me
that's not the case like at the end of
the day like your career will have to
end one day then what you lose purpose
there's a lot of people who work nine to
fives and they enjoy that but if they
lose that nine to five do they lose
their purpose in life and that scares me
I don't my life isn't tied to my job
if YouTube disappears everything else
explodes everything moves on I'm okay
not doing that I'll go figure out my
greatness in something else
that's why it annoys me sometimes when
people look at other celebrities and go
damn I forgot what they were doing or
um
what do they even do anymore I think
they fell off fell off of what who the
[__] cares
fell off of what famous temporary
Fame is so [__] temporary who the
[__] cares that they fell off
maybe they don't want fame anymore
maybe they've ex they've excelled and
they achieved what they wanted and they
moved the [__] on who the [__] are you
to say anything you don't even have
anything to fall off from you dumb [__]
so what [__] high horse are you on
you [__] you're on a donkey ho slip
off you're perfectly fine because you
weren't that high up anyways you [__]
idiot
chill let them be
like even for me right like my channel
isn't as successful as it was before you
think I give a [__] I'm enjoying what
I'm doing
I've made my stamp here on the space
look 10 years from now you guys might
not even see me on here uh maybe not
even 10 maybe five years maybe four
maybe three who knows I may never be on
the space ever again
so enjoy me while I'm here okay
we don't have everything figured out
and that's okay you'll be absolutely
fine
well
how long was this podcast
[__] hold on let me check this out
[Music]
21 [__] minutes Jesus Christ I have
like another like 10 minutes ago doing a
podcast talking yourself is one of the
most difficult things ever you know for
those of you out there that podcast
and you just sit in a room and just
ramble how do you do this this is the
most difficult thing I've ever done in
my life at least when I was streaming I
was talking to people through a chat and
then we could have a discussion after
that and then we could see each other's
reactions and crack up and laugh I am
literally talking to myself
in a room like a [__] maniac
isn't that a [__] trip
uh recently guys I
um
got to send my parents to Korea my
parents haven't been to Korea uh for a
vacation in a very long time every time
they went to Korea uh it was because of
a death or they had some other
obligations and duties and they were
never there just to have fun and the
fact that I was able to send them uh
through my hard work which by the way
was a lot of [__] money
um that should hurt my bank account like
a [__] uh felt really good
um Muriel asked me recently like
um
do you take pride in the fact that you
could send your parents and do this for
them I don't think it's Pride
pride is not it it feels like I
fulfilled my duty
right it makes me happy that I see them
there it has nothing to do with me
there's no pride in it
it makes me very happy that I got to
do something for my parents
that I feel like they deserve
for those of you who have known me for a
very long time you know that
you know financially I didn't grow up
you know that well off my family didn't
um but we always felt like we had more
than we
needed and that was because of how
um my parents raised me and my brother
and to be able to do something for
people who have done so much for us
feels good
it feels like I fulfilled my duty as a
son I don't have a lot of time with them
maybe like another 10 15 years at most
if I'm lucky
and uh that thought at times scares me
that motivates me to do better and to
spend more time and be happy with them
while I still have them here
and to see them and you know my dad is
sending me photos of them in Korea and
he's happy he got to hang out with his
friends that it feels really good
because I feel like they really deserve
it I mean you know my mom said too like
this is probably the last time I'm gonna
go to Korea before I die and
she doesn't know but that's definitely
not going to happen
I'll I'll send them back as much times
as they want if they want to go back and
hang out again maybe in a couple years
two three years
it's not it's not
it doesn't have to be like that
[Music]
um
it's weird man
um and I know like using this as a
comedy podcast but I'm kind of getting
introspective because I'm here talking
to myself in a room like a [__]
maniac
um
sometimes when I look at photos of my
parents
I forget how much time has passed
and I see the age in my mother's face
and I see the age of my father's face
and I can't recognize them
and you know what's so trippy and weird
about that
is that when I go visit them and I see
them face to face I still don't see it
it's the same mother it's the same
father that I've always seen since I was
a kid
even like tangibly where I could hold
their hands hug them
and all this other stuff like I could
smell you know the kimchi and garlic
smell you know Filled Room uh living
room and kitchen or whatever
um
but when I see photos of them it's like
I can't recognize them
trips me out it's a very weird thing to
see
if you don't ever get time back do you
huh
like we never get time back
and seeing my parents age in those
photos kind of you know it [__] me up
in the head a little bit
I don't know if it's because I'm in
denial that they're getting older
or you know because I verbally say a lot
that I do understand but when I see
those photos it trips me out like I
don't recognize the people that I see in
the pictures
you know the time that we have with our
parents are
it may seem very long but it's actually
a lot shorter than you think because I
think the moments that you cherish with
them only happens towards the end
because you start to realize their
mortality
um
it's trippy as [__] man so I'm trying to
be the best son that I can be at this
time by the way that doesn't mean me and
my mom don't fight we'd be going at it
24 [__] seven and I kind of like it
because it shows that she still has fire
in her so maybe I'm doing it on purpose
a little bit but um
it's dope man like if you guys can if
you have a great relationship with your
parents try to spend as much time as you
can with them and you know if let's put
it like this uh if you think you have 20
years with them that means you only have
10 years where it's really good because
those latter 10 years they're not going
to be the same they're going to be a lot
older a little slower not as spry so I'm
doing the best I can to be a good son in
in terms of spending as much time and
quality time with him and talk to them
as as long as I had them here
well guys
um that wraps up this episode of the
crazy person genius brain podcast where
I'm talking to myself because I forgot
to record a podcast before I was going
to leave hope you guys enjoyed this I
know it's not as good as uh when I have
somebody here but I gotta give you guys
something to chew on uh while I'm gone
uh I'll be back
um don't worry I love you very much
we'll see you all next time uh genius
brain every Sundays at 12 p.m
um love you very much
bye